Hey, um, 2017 kinda got away from me
but this is the year I really want to get in shape
You came to the right place.
First thing, what's your diet been like lately?
I mean, I've only been eating W's
Well, sometimes I'll have an L before bed
Maybe in the morning, or during primetime
OK, sign here and wait with all the other eliminated players
Who decided to join a gym on Jan. 2
I'm gonna make some changes in 2018
Yeah, we're gonna make some changes too
This is where all the cardio goes down
How does this work? They really expect
me to move my feet?
God damn newbies
"OK, I give up"
Over here, we have a bunch of giant tires.
Terrible for your back, but great for Instagram.
This is our media spin class.
Repeat after me: I blame my quarterback.
I blame my offensive line,
I blame my defensive coordinator.
I blame Jameis.
This is our spa and wellness area. Perfect for rehab.
Ooh, these Jets are okay.
Ah, the Jets are actually too inconsistent. Aaaaah!!
You got free weights, your cable machines
and of course, bench press.
Higher!!!
Woo! I'm in, let's get started
Ow!
I hate the gym in January